[Musique]
blonde sensuelle jolie un mètre 67
cherche l'homme de nuit ou d'une vie
peut-être
[Musique]
homme trentaine divorcé cherche tendre
complice
[Musique]
rêvant de vos lutter de feu d'artifice
c'est un éternel besoin d'amour
romantisme au bout du jour chercher dans
un quotidien
c'est un éternel besoin d'amour
[Musique]
je pouvais complet toujours
retrouver après la fin du bal les
violons de Stendhal
[Musique]
Juliette aimerait enfin retrouver Alain
rencontrer dans le train entre Bâle et
Berlin
homme ressemblant
[Musique]
recherche femme très femme
c'est un éternel besoin d'amour
romantisme
[Musique]
chercher dans un quotidien banane
c'est un éternel besoin d'amour
se prouver complètement
retrouver après la fin du bal des
violons de standard
c'est un éternel besoin
[Musique]
oui je suis là mais je n'attendais pas
votre appel alors je
[Musique]
vous avez une jolie voix
certains éternel besoin d'amour
je pouvais complet toujours
retrouver après la fin du bal des
violons de standard
c'est un éternel besoin d'amour
[Musique]